So to go over the real time material concepts, what are materials in Unreal?
What is PBR?
Especially if I mention PBR in that intro and you're like, what's PBR?
Well we'll go over that and we'll talk about Fresnel effects and also the view modes inside
of Unreal that you'd expect to see.
So what is a material?
So a material is essentially an applied asset to a mesh that controls its visual look essentially.
So in its simplest form, think of it as paint within the various properties such as the
colour and the finish.
So a material defines how the light interacts with the surface it is applied to.
So you can see on these example materials here, if it's something very porous and seems
to absorb the light, the material can actually set the parameters of how that should look
As well as if it's more of a reflective metallic surface and you want the light to bounce off
it instead of get absorbed, the material can define that inside of Unreal.
The PBR pipeline is a unified lighting and shading system essentially.
So it's physically based rendering is what PBR stands for and it's a better approximation
of the light and material physical interaction.
So it's very intuitive and consistent.
It's physically accurate.
It uses real world physical measurements and a PBR is a combination of the material, which
we spoke about in the previous slide, lighting setups inside of Unreal Engine and then also
the exposure that you use in.
And then Fresnel effect.
So the Fresnel effect states that the amount of light you see reflected from a surface
depends on the viewing angle in which you perceive the surface.
So you can see if you're dead on, 2 to 5% reflection there and on the 90 degree angle,
you've got 100% reflection.
So it creates this nice kind of outlining effect, the Fresnel effect that you see on
the material there.
And the unified shading model within Unreal Engine handles this for us.
So you don't have to do anything custom there.
Unreal Engine's shading model just handles that for you.
And then the different view modes that we can touch upon inside of Unreal.
You can go to the view mode, the view part, sorry, in the middle window and you can select
lit from your editor scene and you can select between a few different things.
There's some optimization and things like this, but the ones that we care about are
along the top here.
So lit, you can see everything within the scene.
Unlit will just show the colors and the textures.
So that might be useful for just previewing if you don't want any lighting information
to be seen.
You could have light ink only, which also just shows the lighting of what you have in
your scene.
And then you can have a detail lighting, which is light and reflections there.
So it might be useful to play around with some of these lighting only or detail lighting.
And you can also toggle through these using alt plus, you know, other different relevant
numbers if you're previewing that content a lot.